the new crowdwork trend that has
completely taken over comedy has grown
well past just the short clips that you
see online starting off with Andrew
Schultz four years ago the crowdwork
special is a new way for comedians to
Showcase their onstage talent in a long
form setting without having to burn
precious material and ever since the
original Schultz special we've seen
multiple crowdwork specials blow up
online from people like stavos Matt rif
neish Patel Mike Cannon and just in the
last two weeks alone both Matteo Lane
and Jessica kerson released their own
crowd works specials on YouTube further
proving that